hey everyone welcome back and let's
write some more neat code today
so today let's look at unique paths so
this is a dynamic programming problem
and it's a relatively straightforward
one compared to a lot of more difficult
dynamic programming problems
we are given a m by n grid
and so the top left in the grid is
always going to be our start value and
so
from our start value it's like a game we
have two choices no matter what position
we're at we
can only move right or we can move
down those are our only choices we can't
go diagonal
we can't go up and we definitely can't
go left so our
goal is to reach the end position or the
finished
position that's always going to be the
bottom right so we start at the top
left but we want to go to the bottom
right and the only question
is how many unique paths are there to
get to the end position
so at first this kind of seems like a
recursive problem right so
we have two choices right we can go down
or we can go
right and then that's a sub problem one
thing to notice is see how from this
start position
we are actually able to move to any
position
in the entire grid but if we move
right from this position what are the
possible spots we can go to well we can
go
right and we can go down so we can
actually go to any spot
here but notice we will never be able to
reach these two elements if we
start from here and similarly if we go
down
from here then what positions can we
reach we can reach any position to the
right or below but we'll never be able
to reach any of these
positions and another thing to notice is
literally any spot in the entire grid
uh the nature of this grid and since we
can go down and we can go right
any spot in this grid will be able to
reach our destination
so we don't have to worry about not
being able to reach
the destination so yeah you might try
this problem recursively right so we
have two decisions go down
or go right and that's great right so
now from here we also have two choices
go
down or go right from here we have two
choices
go down or go right
you kind of notice though there's some
repeated work
obviously we can get to this position
two different ways so
in that case we're gonna end up doing
repeated work right from
this uh way that we got here we're gonna
we can go down and we can go
right and we're gonna repeat that over
here right go
down or go right so if we're doing depth
first search recursively
one thing we can do is have a cache so
for every row column
position so for example in this
position we cache the result so if we
ever
reach this spot multiple times we will
be able to store that and we won't have
to run
debt for search again because debt for
search is pretty expensive
and so what is this value even going to
store well
this is recursive so for each position
we're actually calculating the number of
ways
we can reach the destination right and
if we can compute that for
every single like square then
we can compute that for the original
square
right basically what i'm saying is the
result that we're looking for
is actually equal so let's say we call
this spot
r we call this spot down right so this
is r
for right this is d for down the result
that we're looking for is actually the
sum of r plus d right but then you might
ask well how do we compute
r and how do we compute d well r is just
gonna be
r has a value to the right of it and it
has a value below it right
so if we want to compute this value
we can just take the right and down
values
and get them right but so what's the
what ends up being the base case
so with all that in mind what ends up
actually being the base case well
so this is the ending position right so
how many ways
from the ending position are there how
many unique paths are there to
get to itself well we can choose
to define that as one so if we've
defined that value as one we'll notice
that things actually work out pretty
nicely
because let's let's take a look at this
cell right we want to take the bottom
value
and the right value and then add them up
and then that's what we're going to put
in this spot
but we see that there's nothing below it
right that's out of bounds
what we can say is well we'll just
define that to be 0 right
we'll define every value out of bounds
to be zero so if we ever need them well
we can just say
that they're zero so then what becomes
the value that we place in the cell well
we can take
the right value which is one and the
bottom value which is zero add them
together and then we get
one so we can just put a one over here
right and
you might notice well what if we want to
compute the value in this position
well the exact same thing will take
place right the value below is zero the
value to the right is one
so we can say that there's one way from
this position
to reach the end result and now what's
what actually is that
path well we can we can't move down
right that's out of bounds so we can
only choose to move
right and then right and then we'll be
able to get to the result
and you can see that's true for every
position in the bottom row so we're just
going to fill
these to be one and you might be able to
see how
we are going to arrive at the dynamic
programming solution now
so the first thing for us to do is to
compute this bottom row now let's start
doing the next
row right because our ultimate goal is
to be able to do this value we can work
our way
from the bottom to the left and then
from here
to the left and then keep doing that and
eventually we'll
arrive at the result so what about this
position
well it has a zero to the right of it
because the right is out of bounds it
has a one
below it so we'll take zero plus one
again we get
one now what about this spot this spot
actually has a value below it
and a value to the right of it and those
values are one and one respectively so
the sum is gonna be two and that makes
sense right because if you
start here there's one path going to the
right and then going down right that's
one path to get to the result
and there's another path going down and
going
right that lets us get to the result so
it makes sense that this would be
two unique paths to get to the result
and from here on out it's basic addition
right so down is one
right is two add those together we get
three here we get one plus three that's
going to be
four add this together with this that's
gonna be five
add these two together that's gonna be
six add these two together that's gonna
be seven
and so you notice now we have filled in
the second row it looks a little bit
different than the first row right
the bottom was all ones and now the only
thing for us to do is to get this
last row so we look down and we look
right that's one plus zero so we're
going to get a one
notice how the entire first column is
one
that's actually always going to be true
right because think about it from any
position
in the rightmost column the only
decision we can do is move
down so there's only going to be one
path
to the result so this is going to be two
plus
one this is going to be three plus three
this is going to be four plus six this
is going to be five plus ten
this is going to be six plus fifteen and
so finally
we are at our start position so we can
take the bottom and right values
7 plus 21 add them together we get 28
so that tells us if we start here there
are
28 different paths we can use
to get to the result 28 unique paths
and when you look at the picture it
actually looks more like a math problem
than a coding problem right and that's
because it is you can actually
calculate the number of ways from the
top left i think in constant time if you
have like a
math equation but i don't know a ton
about it i'm just going to stick to the
dynamic programming solution
so let's do what we just did in the
picture so i'm going to have
a row and this is initially going to be
the bottom row it's going to be
the length of the number of rows that we
have which is
n but since it's a grid you could
probably use either m
or n and so since we know the bottom row
is going to be all ones we can start
going through the other rows
so we can go through all of the other
rows except for the last one so
m minus one and for each row we're going
to compute
a new row so this new row is going to be
above
the old row and so it's going to be the
same dimensions of course
we'll initialize it to all ones and to
avoid
the edge case of having to check out of
bounds what i'm going to do
is go through every position every
column except
the rightmost column and we can do that
like this because we know the rightmost
column
or the last value in every single row is
always going to be
one right i showed that in the drawing
and so we're going to
start at the second to last position
keep going until we get to the beginning
and go
in reverse order so we're going from
right to left
and we know that the new row so if we're
computing new row of
j it's going to be new
row of j plus 1 so the
this is the right value and the value
below is just going to be
the old row at index j and so with this
loop we'll be able to compute the new
row and so after we do that we can
update the row so the old row is now
going to be set to the
new row and so it's going to keep doing
that until we
end up getting the last or rather the
first row the top
row that we actually want to compute so
after this has been executed that's
what's going to happen and what we
actually want to return though
is in that first row which will be in
this variable
we want the first value so at index 0
that's what we're going to return
so now we can run our code and by the
way
so it is pretty efficient because we did
this in o
of n times n time and the memory
complexity is just the
big o of n because that's the length of
a
row so i hope this was helpful if you
enjoyed
please like and subscribe it supports
the channel a lot and i'll hopefully
see you pretty soon